so I often get asked Pat how important
is it on what I named my company or even
how do I go about name of my business or
today's episode is to answer that
question for you but before we get into
it I want you to think about something
here just as important it is on what you
named your kid one day or you already
have it's just as important with your
name your company because that's how
people will see that company or the name
for the rest of its life or career how
many kids did you have in school who
hated their names they don't like their
names or they would call by middle name
I had a sergeant in the army whose last
name was hooker
sergeant hooker he couldn't stand it but
he had his last name so same exact thing
goes with naming a business because in a
Bible a lot of parents like to name
their kids after the Bible Paul John
Luke Mark Matthew Peter but you don't
hear Judas no one's going to name their
kid Judas first thing you go search
Judas
oh my gosh this is Judas that's your
name or a doll you don't hear a doll
same goes with the name in your company
so let me give you eight different
examples number one your name your
company after two words that make up
your company's name value payment it
brings value combined with entertainment
or Volkswagen and German I think it
means average folks a car wagon right in
1934 the history of it is Hitler one had
a car for two adults and three kids
that's the walks wagon and he called it
a car for Masse's that's how that whole
thing got started you can go read about
it online
number two its words that have no
meaning Twitter you got Yahoo you got
Google there's not a meaning to it but
it's catchy people like your Twitter
word Yahoo work Google work there was a
formula for Yahoo and google - oh it's
at work we were used to it number three
meaning in a different language
Verizon we all know Verizon Verizon came
up with Veritas which in Latin means the
truth combined with horizon the truth
horizon becomes Verizon it worked for
them number four crowdsourcing let me
ask my phone to see what they think
about this name let me ask my family let
me ask everybody on Facebook what do you
think about the stem - trouble with that
could be now once you put it out there
what then you want to go without seeing
the type of so many times people say I
don't like this name I don't like this
and I don't like this and I don't like
this and I like this thing
then if you go with one you already have
an audience that don't like any of the
name you went with so it could backfire
when you do that number five your name
Charles Schwab K Merrill Lynch Morgan
Stanley Hilton Sheraton Hyatt your name
but it's got to be important what name
you go with at what time Ray Kroc and a
movie founder said something very
interesting he said why do you like the
name McDonald's so much
he said it's all-american its welcomed
it it's warm he says would you ever go
to a restaurant called crocks no but you
would go to McDonald's it worked look
yourself or where he was to know that
his name wouldn't have worked so it's
eco didn't get no when said I want my
name to be it he used McDonald's six
acronym MBA MBC TLC IBM acronyms works a
lot of people do it with three letters
or four seven explanatory Lego Lego was
founded in Denmark Lego has a meaning a
Lego has a meaning of leg gods which
means play well and Danish or in Latin
amis play together right there was a
meaning of why they call a Lego utilize
the name I like the name I love Lego
till today I make Legos on my kids it
makes you feel a certain when you go
with a name like that i love the name
Lego and what it means to us as people
using a number eight this is an
interesting story here some of you have
read the book girlboss written by Sophia
Amoruso I believe prior to her writing
that book that blew up and did very well
she started a clothing line a vintage
clothing line called Nasty Gal
what she didn't do before she started a
company is she didn't research if
anybody else own that domain so when she
said I'm announcing my company name is
going to be nasty Dell everybody went to
the website nasty girl ended up being a
point site so kind of backfired on you
got to do research a little bit before
name a company she ended up buying the
domain I think for $8,000 so do research
before you name any company name you're
going to pay now thanks to avoid number
one sensitivity and sensitivity has to
do with timing Washington Redskins may
have worked 60 years ago it's not going
to work today
a company I think based out of Michigan
who sells coffee when you think about
coffee bean that works these guys decide
an in good company you know name
your company okay
that's 72 something stores they were you
know so many people complain about it
they ended up changing their company
name from to Bigsby because it's
a sensitivity fact they didn't even
think about the fact that's offensive
but their audience did number two or
Wiegel talk to your attorney what do you
think about this name is there anything
like this out there what do I have to
look for when we started value taming we
knew there was a vitamin come out of
Germany and we found that it has nothing
to do with here so we can go with
starting the company called value
tainment number thirty-two long
sometimes too long the name makes too
long of an email makes too longaville
website makes too many opportunities for
me to misspell when I typed in the
domain there's just way too many
opportunities there to screw up so think
about all those things there before you
picking a name for your company and if
you've got any questions any thoughts
any comments comment on the bottom and
if you have not subscribed to this
channel here be sure to click on this
button you can subscribe and click on
the alert button to be part of the
notification squad we care about
[Music]